hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and i've been saying for a
while now that the current arc and boku
no hero
is probably the best one yet but these
latest insane events in the story just
clinched it for me
my favorite character in the entire
series is finally back
after 140 chapters and i don't mean just
back i mean back in business
this was so crazy this current battle is
easily the most epic villain vs hero
clash in the history of boku no hero
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like
and a comment it really does help and if
you're new to the channel
or maybe just haven't subscribed make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain
boku no hero manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned now it was
definitely hard to wait
an extra week for a new installment of
the story because of how epic this arc
has been
but man was the wait ever worth
it i did not expect that this crazy
lemelian comeback would happen so soon
and under these circumstances but hey
i am not complaining this is hype of
course we were all hoping that media
would get his quirk back at some point
and it was heavily implied that arie
could restore his quirk when she learns
to control her own quirk
but after waiting for literal years in
real world time
i did not think that meteo's quirk would
come back
at this point but that said i am so glad
that he did come back
because i've been waiting so long for my
boy to be back
in action meteo is the goat in my
opinion
as you guys know if you've been watching
this channel i did believe that the
dobby reveal would happen
in this arc and on this battlefield in
jakku
i mentioned it many times in previous
videos but
this meteor comeback took me by surprise
again it's not that i wasn't expecting
it to happen eventually but the way it
was handled
definitely surprised me alright i had to
address the myrial thing right away
because i was way too excited and i will
talk more about it later
but now let's delve deeper into the
story the new chapter starts off right
before
best genius made his jump from the
airplane something that we saw at the
end of the previous
chapter genus recognizes right away the
same thing that i was talking about in
my two previous boku no hero videos
the general public's faith in the heroes
has already been shaky due to all
might's retirement
and the obvious upsurge in villain
activity and now
dobby's scathing allegations against the
number one pro hero
and all might successor represent yet
another major blow
against the reputation of the entire
hero society
but best genius refuses to allow dobby
to succeed
in his evil plan and so he drops down
from the airplane
engulfs makia and the other villains
with those giant cables
and he vows to bring a ray of hope back
to the people of japan
genus is definitely a badass in this
chapter
and bakugou is clearly happy to see that
his former mentor
is still alive but dabi is genuinely
shocked
to see genus dobby was entirely
convinced that the dead body he saw
and which he believed to be genus was a
real dead body
so he really believed that hawks had
gone as far as to kill genus
just to convince him that he was a
villain this now really begs the
question
if this really was a real dead body
whose body was it i mean it's highly
unlikely that dobby would be tricked so
easily so there must be something
to this claim that the body was real so
did hawks kill someone else
and make the body look like genus i mean
that's unlikely he is a hero after all
but did he maybe steal a dead body from
somewhere else this is a very intriguing
question but we'll have to wait and see
how the plot to trick the villains
really went down
from hawk's perspective regardless of
what happened though
dobby is pretty upset at this revelation
since this means that he just gave the
wrong information to millions of people
during his public broadcast
as a result dobby's flames surge
and this kind of makes him look like a
super saiyan and i mean especially now
that his hair went from black to white
our boy dobby just went from base form
to ultra instinct
real quick as shoto confronts his older
brother toya
aka dabi the villains realize that they
must wake up shigaraki so that shigaraki
can order makia to break through
those cables makia has incredible
superhuman strength
but in order to access that power he
needs to receive a direct order from his
master
now that he has arrived at jakku his
previous order has been fulfilled
so he is no longer at full power and
also the effects of that sleeping agent
that momo gave him
might be starting to kick in the problem
for the villains
lies in the fact that shigaraki has been
severely injured and he isn't even
physically capable
of issuing an order at this moment
spinner attempts to physically
shake shigaraki awake by using his mouth
since the rest of his body is tied up
with genus cables
negere then descends upon spinner in
order to prevent him from waking up
shigaraki but
just before she can take spinner out of
commission
dobby uses his flames to blast nejire
out of the air shoto deku and endeavor
are horrified as a clearly injured and
badly burnt
negere falls to the ground and dobby
then uses this moment
to go the endeavor once more as
dabi's overpowered flames literally burn
those massive cables off of his body he
tells endeavour that it was his own fire
that just burned yet another starry-eyed
kid with a bright
future this is a very meaningful
statement from dobby
because we have to remember just what he
is trying to accomplish here dobby wants
to make endeavors suffer
as much as possible and he blames
endeavour for what happened to him
as a kid but he also wants endeavor to
blame himself
for all of dobby's actions as a villain
and of course he wants the hero society
to blame endeavor
as well that is why dobby says that it
was
endeavour's own flames that just burnt
negere it was endeavour who created
dobby in the first place
in more ways than one and so endeavour
should be held responsible for
all of dobby's sins at least according
to dobby
i personally disagree with this of
course no matter what endeavour did to
dobby as a child
dobby is an adult now and he is
responsible for his
own actions but i could definitely
understand why
dobby is saying these things he wants
endeavor to feel guilty he wants him to
suffer and he wants endeavor to be seen
as guilty
in the eyes of the public and in fact
dobby's big brain strategy
appears to be working here endeavour is
clearly dazed
and in shock because of all of this and
as a result endeavor is clearly not
on his a-game even though the current
drastic situation
definitely needs the number one pro hero
to get it together endeavour just can't
believe
what he is seeing best genius knows that
this is not good
if the number one pro hero is defeated
here then the entire country will fall
to pieces no one will have faith in the
heroes anymore
no one will feel safe or protected and
as a result
society will descend into panic and
chaos
meanwhile shigaraki manages to regain
consciousness
in a surprisingly funny moment
considering everything that's happening
now
shigaraki thinks to himself that he's
feeling itchy but he can't move because
of the cables so he can't scratch
himself
i personally thought this was kind of
funny but of course we know that
when shigaraki gets itchy it's never a
laughing matter
so shigaraki calls out to makia and
orders him to
break free you know not because he wants
to destroy the entire hero society or
anything he just needs to scratch
that itch as machia suddenly goes from
zero to berserk
yet again and as genus struggles to
contain the power of the newly
invigorated machia
the chapter switches focus away from the
main
battlefield on the secondary battlefield
a bunch of the other heroes are still
battling against the various
high and nomu it seems that the heroes
have already dealt successfully with
more than half
of the nomu but then four of the high
end
suddenly break away from the others and
rush towards the main battlefield
up to this point all those high end nomu
were just kind of running around like
wild beasts and aimlessly attacking the
heroes
but now out of nowhere these four nomu
became
organized and coordinated vernon tries
to go after the four intelligent nomu
but then a giant worm-like nomu with
huge sharp teeth
attacks burnin from behind but then
vernon is seemingly saved by someone
wearing
a white shirt that someone punches the
nomu
right into its exposed brain and even
though we don't see what happens next we
can assume that burning is safe
to me it looked like that nomu was just
taken down
for the count back on the main
battlefield though machia is going
buck wild and genus is seriously
struggling to keep him contained within
the cables
at the same time a total brokey showdown
is happening between shoto
and dabi shoto is furious at his older
brother
and he screams adabi that his actions
almost killed their
other brother natsu but the thought of
natsu dying
doesn't affect dobby at all and he just
says that hey
that would have hurt endeavors so it's
all good when shoto freaks out about
dobby dismissing the potential death of
their own brother so casually
dobby explains that he has lost all
feeling compassion
and empathy dobby doesn't care about
anything anymore
not even his own family and he is
perfectly willing to kill his own
siblings just to hurt
endeavour it's ironic that dobby has
become so obsessed with getting revenge
on endeavor because of course it was
endeavour's
own obsession with surpassing all might
that caused this whole mess
in the first place so in the end dabi
became just as obsessed as endeavour
they are just obsessed with different
things as
dabi threatens to kill shoto the four
nomu from earlier
arrive on the scene while he has been
able to focus
strictly on machia best genius has been
able to successfully restrain him
but now that the four nomus are rushing
towards him
genus won't be able to restrain machia
and defend himself against the nomu
at the same time at this point the
situation looks desperate for the heroes
yet again and as ida grabs negere and
takes her away to safety
deku is racking his brain to come up
with a way to help
genus but unfortunately his body is so
injured and exhausted after that battle
with shigaraki that he simply can't do
much
at least for now but then in an
insane turn of events that i definitely
didn't see coming
the one and only meteo togata shows up
on the scene and not only does he show
up but we see him using his quirk again
he's using permeation meteo smashes the
nomu
in an instant providing backup for genus
and of course deck was shocked to see
his senpai
our boy lamilian back in
action that is how this unbelievable
chapter ends
and man what a freaking chapter lemelian
is probably my favorite character in the
entire series
an absolute legend and a chad of epic
proportions
so i really missed him as a character
ever since he got sidelined
after he lost the ability to use his
quirk back in the overhaul arc
as you will recall media lost his quirk
after he was struck by one of overhaul's
quirk destroying bullets
and that happened way back in chapter
152
and now 140 chapters later
meteo finally has his quirk back awesome
but also
how did his queer come back we don't
know yet
but it was implied earlier on that
because aries body was used to create
the quirk destroying bullets
once arie learned to fully control her
quirk rewind
she would likely be able to reverse the
effects of the quirk destroying bullets
it's probably a good guess that this is
exactly what happened but
theoretically there could be other
explanations for how meteo got his quirk
back
such as i don't know like an
artificially created antidote for the
bullets or the effects of the bullets
just wore off after a long time
or something like that my personal guess
is probably airy
and if that is the case then arie is
learning to control rewind
which is a big deal knowing how
incredibly overpowered aries quirk is
her ability to control it and bring out
its huge potential could be a game
changer
in the story the true potential rewind
goes far beyond just restoring muriel's
quirk
so we'll have to stay tuned and see what
horikoshi has planned for airy
and rewind i don't know about you guys
but i'm so hyped that my boy
mirio is back and what an entrance by
the way
that was amazing as i said before i did
always think that he would regain his
quirk at some point
but with everything that we've already
seen happening during this arc
the timing of this definitely caught me
by surprise
let me know what you guys think were you
surprised by meteo's comeback
and are you as glad to see him back as i
am also
do the villains still stand a chance now
that meteo
is back in the game personally i think
that dobby still has some tricks up his
sleeve
he kind of went super saiyan during this
chapter so i don't think we've seen his
full destructive potential just yet
not to mention that both shigaraki and
makia still pose a massive threat
to the heroes oh and then we have the
nomu and
toga of course oh and speaking of toga
imagine if horikoshi trolls us and it
turns out that toga got some of meteo's
blood somehow
and this is actually her infiltrating
the heroes by pretending to be a
recovered meteo
brah that would be so messed up but i
think i've been playing among us a
little bit too much lately
so hopefully that doesn't happen i do
not want
all my medial comeback hype to be in
vain
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel please leave a like
right now it really does help and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
just haven't subscribed
make this the video do subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications feel free to hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one
tier patrons including ingrata the world
a quiet respect liam thompson pate heffa
rithian y x emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life chanel baked buddhist
tungsten tarkis
and denki kaminari and finally thanks to
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
joe stanton rathune de ora very gucci
jessica calefon
alicia octor hinokami and water bonnie
parks the red-haired raven florian
joy and garcia mcshamus jack watches
anime
amanda c deadly saint high school dxd73
matthew cruz and anthony schreiber if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you